we're joined by the investigative
journalist and co-author of looking for
madeleine that's robin swan
uh robin swan welcome to you i say a
digger and a sniffer dog i think that
probably underestimates the police
presence there our
local source on the ground says anything
approaching a hundred german police
officers on the scene
so it sounds like a pretty significant
operation
it does indeed although there's nothing
in this case that has ever
uh done quietly or in in moderation it
seems sometimes
the uh as you know this suspect
christian b
emerged back on june the 3rd when the
german police
came forward with an actual plea to the
public to help them identify
possible new leads in connection with
the man they characterized as the prime
suspect
and they were hoping uh to get some
leads on a
cell phone call that was made to
christian bee's cell phone
on the night that madeleine disappeared
there in prior to lose
and as far as i know they have been
inundated with leads
um some 16 specifically relating to the
phone
and a couple of thousand as far as i
know related to other matters in
relation to christian b
so we don't actually know why the search
is taking place today
or what they're exactly looking for as
your reporters said
are they looking in for something
specifically to do with madeleine's
disappearance
or are they looking for some other kind
of incriminating evidence
about the main suspect christian b to do
with any of the other cases in which
he's now been implicated
yeah hans christian walters that the
lead german prosecutor in this robin
says they have concrete evidence not
forensic evidence
um that's that division that that that
strange dichotomy
we've got we're sure there's concrete
evidence linking him to a murder
but we don't have the forensic evidence
i mean when they start digging you
wonder whether the second element of
that might be what they're after
you certainly you certainly do um
the police sources i've spoken with
um some closely linked to the bka
have have said to me that you know these
this
prosecutor is not the kind of man with a
reputation for speaking
wildly or out of turn his use of his
phrase
concrete evidence and his conviction his
seeming conviction
that this suspect is involved and that
madeleine
is dead um
they say he's not the kind of man who
would be saying that loosely
that said they clearly don't have what
they need to go forward with a
prosecution on this case
and that is what they so desperately
need
both to bring some kind of closure to
the mccann family if this is indeed the
case or and because if they are going to
prosecute anyone in connection with
madeleine's disappearance
the time uh is rather running short
because of the the statute of
limitations on this kind of crime in
portugal where the crime took place
yeah which reminds us doesn't it of how
you've got different jurisdictions
involved here
uh christian b may be in a prison in
germany but we had
uh the portuguese who were digging
around some wells in recent weeks you've
got the
scotland yard was saying as far as we're
concerned it's still a missing person's
inquiry
ultimately who's whose jurisdiction are
we in here i'm guessing
yes okay crime on the face of it appears
to have been committed in portugal with
the british victim
but the the individual who's the chief
suspect is there in germany
yes and i think we have to be very
careful about this it would seem to me
it's a it would be a crime prosecutable
in portugal because that's where it
seems to have taken place
uh but we don't know and
one of the problems in this case at the
moment
is the germans concerned that christian
bee might be allowed
out of prison because he is only in
prison at the moment on a drugs charge
although he has been convicted in
connection with the rape of a 72 year
old
american woman in a violent rape uh
he is appealing that conviction on the
basis of the fact that
uh his lawyers claim he was extradited
and
uh only on the drugs charge and
therefore he cannot be imprisoned in
germany on the basis of this
of the fresh conviction on the rape case
so all of that legal
uh tangle has to be sorted out before
the prosecution can go forward
robin you don't need me to tell you how
much public interest over the years
there has been in this
in this investigation but and obviously
sometimes you get a lot of uh as far as
the family are concerned at
advance adverse internet
uh commentary that goes with this but
you've hinted at this already what is
the prospect do you think
of a story like this you know leading
the bulletins today
actually yielding a piece of information
from a member of the public
um that actually can lead to something
definitive in this case
well long ago when this case started
the reason madeleine's name became well
known to all of us is because
the men and women who run the best
organizations in the world for finding
missing children
have always believed that getting a
child's name and face
out there is the best hope
of turning up in fresh information that
remains the case today
little bits of information can come in
it has always been said that there is
someone who knows what happened to
madeleine
and relationships change over time
loyalties change over time and even
people's memories of what they
saw can be you know sort of
assisted by seeing something over and
over again so
in as much as this is terribly difficult
for madeleine's family to go through
this
time and time again the little bits of
information
may still help find her find find what
happened to madeleine and that's
ultimately the most important thing
robin swan good to talk to you thanks
very much thanks colin